[Music]
hong kong police used to parade in the
more restrained british marching style
this year for the first time they
adopted the chinese goosestep
a city brought to hill
the balhania flower of hong kong beneath
china's golden stars the control of one
country one party and one man
the policy of one country two systems
having been tested and proved time and
again
meets the fundamental interests of the
country and the chinese nation
for a long time of course hong kong
stood apart from china under british
rule for a century
today marks 25 years since the uk handed
over hong kong to china
the last colonial governor lord patton
says china has not honored the
commitments it made china promised that
hong kong's way of life would remain
unchanged for 50 years i put that in a
treaty has it kept that promise
no
absolutely not they catastrophically um
uh bro and comprehensively broke their
word about um about hong kong in which
was set out in a treaty lodged at the
united nations which guaranteed hong
kong its continuing way of life until 19
until 2047
and and also um promised uh that china
would develop democracy um in in hong
kong well fat chance of that happening
with the secret police taking over
it was democracy that protesters asked
for peacefully at first in
2019 they became increasingly violent in
the face of heavy-handed policing
but at the end of the year many still
had hope
then beijing imposed a sweeping national
security law which the british
government says has stifled opposition
scores of pro-democracy activists have
been arrested and now languish in jail
and it has led to an exodus of hong
kongers many settling in the uk
simon chang is one of them he fled hong
kong after being detained and tortured
by the chinese authorities i feel the
future is bleak because when i watch
this ceremony it's full of ecstasy but
only in the official way
but as we know there has majority of the
hong kong citizens previously they vote
for pro democracy game but all their own
representatives are either in jail or in
exile
a lot of even i would say a majority of
hong kong citizens cannot be
voiced and cannot be
properly heard
and i think that is so sad for the
moment
if there was any doubt about beijing's
plans for hong kong it was removed by
the selection of its new chief executive
sworn in today
john lee was the hard-line security
chief who crushed the 2019 protest and
was the architect of the national
security law for which he has been
sanctioned by the united states
he will govern the people of hong kong
with beijing's blessing
but real power and absolute control
belongs to one man alone tom cheshire
sky news beijing